you useless pores  the ruins  in kosh forest  are overrun  with toxic law robbers  hmm  well well looks like we got some  competition  [Laughter]  you ain't going nowhere  ghetto boys  adventurer  are you okay  robbers are after the tablet piece  what do they want it for  that's one popular hunk of rock  you're too late  i already gave it to the boss  you'll never get it  from our demon  a demon  i fear this much  this curse is far too powerful to be  human in origin  we must find whoever these robbers are  working for  let's find the warden of the kohl's  ruins  maybe they can point us in the right  direction  foreign  [Music]  um  you useless porters the toxic law  robbers have their hideouts set up in  some isolated place